Cái cuộc quan lý đe điều và phòng trống thương tài cho biết báo xúc người đã làm năm
1 người chết, tăng 1 năm rồi sau với hút qua 1 2 tháng người.
1 bộn người còn mất tích và 1 chăm sóm mi tư người bị thương.
Trong đó, sạt nửa đất, lúc quấn khi 1.5 người từ vòng, rộng lốc làm 1 người thương
mà, thương tài cũng làm 8 chăm 4 mi chỉ nhà sập.
Hơn 1 chăm bệ mẹ 2 nghìn nhà hư hồng, tốc mái, gần sóm mi sống nghi nhà ngập.
Trong đó có hơn chính nghi nhà tại lâu kai, hơn 1 mi nhà tại thương quá.
Gần tảm mi chính nghi nhà tại lũo ngọt vào năm 1 mi nhà tại dần bị thương hồng.
Hơn 1 mi nhà tại thị sản và hơn nửa chở ra súc ra cầm bị quấn trôi.
Ngập lúc, sạt lửa, an tác tải gần bệ, 1 xóo trăm tiền rau thông, cất tình bắt bộ, bắt trùng bộ.
Cơn bây bàn, gình mẹ kè, bởi sông, bởi biển.
Năm 1 tảm, kì lồ mẹ tình mường, 2 xong linh bà công trình thuy lợi bị hương hồng.
Gần 1 mi nhà làm trong diểm trường học bị an hưởng.
Cơn tảm, gình tảm trong cuộc biệt.
Hình tảm bị mất điện.
Tổng thị thái kinh tế xơ bộ, 1 lâm, 1 tảm xam xóm viên tư thì đồng.
Hà tế ứng chữ thị thái nặng nhất, khoảng xóm viên tì đồng.
Thế đến là tuyên quan, bàn nghiên tì.
Lào cai hương hành in bày xam tì.
Và nghe an hành in một xam tì đồng.
Nhanh kì thời tiêu xẻ với các địa phương biển hưởng, rõ bảo số mời.
Hẹn mùa hai tháng mời, bàn chủ tịch i bàn trung hương mặt trận thục quốc biệt nâm.
Đá tổ chức lẽ bắt đầu của hộ đồng bà bị thiệt hại, rõ cân bảo số mời gây ra.
Tại lẽ bắt đầu, thay mặt bàn trung tịch i bàn trung hương mặt trận thục quốc biệt nâm.
Uy viên bộ trực chi, biệt thương hương mặt trung hương mặt trận thục quốc biệt nâm.
Hãy tệ lẽ bắt đầu, bàn vận đồng tự trở trung hương.
Đá côn bố dành xác mời bệ tình thành phố nhận hộ trở đơn một.
Tương môn tự trở trung hương.
Hắc cuộc thục quả tình bảo số mời với tổng số tiền 2,5.
Trong ló vấn bộ cho bắt tình nghe an, tính và khoảng chi, mối tình 3 mì tì đồng.
2 tình mình bình và thương hã, mối tình 2 mì tì đồng.
3 tình là cai của thọt chuyển quan mối tình 5 mì lắm tì đồng.
6 tình lặng sơn, cao bằng xin la, thánh viên, khoảng ninh, tương viên.
Và 3 tình 4 thài phòng, vĩ và đả nắng mối tình thành 4 mời tì đồng.